Україна посідає сто тридцяте місце у світі
за рівнем ВВП та за рівнем бідності.
Такі дані навів кандидат у президенти України,
міський голова Львова Андрій Садовий під час зустрічі з виборцями.
Ми сьогодні за рівнем ВВП 130-ті у світі.
І за рівнем бідності ми 130-ті у світі.
Розмір валового внутрішнього продукту - один з основних показників,
за якими оцінюється добробут країни.
ЯкщоВВП зростає, значить, зростає добробут населення,
збільшуються зарплати і податкові надходження до бюджету.
За даними Світового банку, за підсумками 2017 року
ВВП України склав сто дванадцять мільярдів доларів,
і це - шістдесяте місце у світі,
а не сто тридцяте, як стверджує Андрій Садовий.
Дані оновлюються щороку наприкінці червня,
тому поки що немає показників за 2018-й рік.
Імовірно, Андрій Садовий, кажучи про 130 місце,
мав на увазі останній звіт Міжнародного валютного фонду
щодо показника ВВП на душу населення,
згідно з яким Україна посіла 134 місце у світі.
І це справді найгірша позиція в Європі.
Цей показник є мірою випуску продукції на душу населення,
тобто загальну вартість виготовленої продукції
ділять на кількість людей, які живуть в країні.
Щоправда, українські економісти вважають,
що цей показник був вирахований з двома неточностями.
По-перше, експерти МВФ виходили з того,
що населення України складає понад 44 мільйони осіб,
що на два мільйони більше, ніж актуальна офіційна статистика.
По-друге, українські експерти вважають, що, визначаючи цей показник,
варто було б тимчасово не враховувати українців,
які мешкають на окупованих територіях Донецької та Луганської областей,
а також в окупованому Криму.
Адже працюючи на непідконтрольних територіях, їхній внесок до ВВП
їхній внесок до ВВП не впливає на українську економіку.
Тому, на думку експертів, загальний ВВП варто було б ділити
не на 44 мільйони, а на кількість  українців,
які реально живуть і працюють на економіку країни.
Щодо заяви Андрія Садового про те, що Україна перебуває
на 130-му місці за рівнем бідності, то не зовсім зрозуміло,
якими дослідженнями керувався мер Львова.
Для визначення рівня життя за основу іноді беруть
показник ВВП за паритетом купівельної спроможності.
Він визначає не лише, яка сума в доларах
припадає на одного мешканця, але й оцінює,
скільки товарів і послуг людина може купити за ці гроші.
За цим показником, як підрахували у Світовому банку,
Україна посідає 116-те місце у світі.
Водночас в оприлюдненому ООН глобальному рейтингу якості життя
за 2017 рік Україна опустилася на чотири позиції
і посідає 88-е місце зі ста вісімдесяти дев'яти країн.
На фоні своїх сусідів - Росії та Білорусі -
це теж не дуже втішні показники.
Росія посідає 49-у сходинку,  а Білорусь - 53-тю.
Визначальними критеріями для авторів цього індексу є такі показники,
як тривалість життя, рівень освіти та рівень доходівгромадян.
Дані, наведені кандидатом у президенти Андрієм Садовим, не є точними.
Україна не займає 130 місце у світі за рівнем ВВП.
А щодо рівня бідності, цей показник не можна брати
за основу для оцінювання рівня життя у країні.
Тим не менше в України справді не дуже втішні позиції
щодо ВВП за паритетом купівельної спроможності.
А за рейтингом якості життя ООН, Україна суттєво поступається
своїм сусідам - Росії та Білорусі.